yeah i mean no doubt trump wants to run
for president and 24 he's raising money
to do so he has an announce because if
he announces now in uh 22 campaign
finance laws immediately kick in that
will constrict his fundraising for his
political action committees so he's not
going to
formally announce till next year
um
donald trump has problems
no doubt about it
uh he didn't handle uh the sixth january
sixth thing well
uh he continues to harp on the election
which is not a good political way to be
because he does have a strong record
have you said that do you look
at him
about the about january 6 yeah
he doesn't listen to anybody donald
trump never listens to anybody it's part
of his charm
he never has listened to anybody
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host of no spin news and the author
of the new book killing the killers the
secret war against terrorists bill
o'reilly welcome to the reuben report
thanks send me back dave appreciate it
how are you doing bill i'm doing well i
have to tell you as someone that just
got my second book out i am told because
i'm looking at the cover of your book
right now
this is your 17th number one bestseller
how many how many books have you written
in the first place
25
a lot of them children's books uh off
the o'reilly factor
but uh all of the killing books have hit
number one and uh the killing series
uh the killing the killers is the
eleventh book in the series the most
successful non-fiction book series of
all time
and uh that's pretty stunning when you
think about it and humbling for me
for sure what what do you consider
yourself first i mean do you consider
yourself a pundit first or a journalist
do you do you consider yourself a
journalist in a traditional sense or is
it an author first does it matter what's
first
i'm a journalist slash historian
master's degree in
broadcast journalism from boston u
network experience at cbs and abc
seen it all 84 countries so i'm a
journalist first but i bring a
history perspective because i used to
teach high school history so it's an
interesting combination it served me
well
so let's uh i want to talk about the
book obviously but let's dive into just
some of the stuff going on right now
obviously as we're sitting here uh
abortion and the reversal of roe v wade
is the big one uh
first off are you shocked that putting
aside the decision that we are not
talking about the leak anymore that that
seems to have come and gone and is sort
of irrelevant at this point or at least
in terms of what the mainstream media
will discuss relative to it
i'm not shocked because you got merrick
garland the attorney general he has no
interest in finding out who leaked that
out
from melito's office garland have any
interest in finding that out because it
would hurt
but um and
you have the head of the u.s marshals
service
supervising it no updates no press
conferences nothing and they're just
hoping it goes away i mean look we live
in a country now where there really
isn't a criminal justice system or a
civil justice system for that matter
anymore it's evaporated now you have
little fiefdoms all over the place and
the prosecutor in new york city doesn't
want to uh prosecute somebody who stabs
another person then he's not going to
prosecute
and the governors and the president and
everybody else allows it to happen so
that's where we are
you've been warning about this stuff for
a long time do you do you ever feel boy
i guess i was right they said a lot of
bad things about me but i guess i was
right about some of this stuff
well when you're right they're going to
say bad things about you dave
that's just the way america works if
you're right you're going to get
hammered i read a book called culture
warrior way back if you read that book
everything i said in that book and that
was a mid 2000 you know
about 2004 i think
came true
i could see the trend way before it
happened
because what we have is cowardly
politicians
i mean that's what it comes down to
80 percent maybe maybe 70 percent of the
elected people in this country are
cowards
they're not interested in helping the
folks are interested in maintaining
their power
so when you have that
and you have an electorate that's
largely uneducated people don't know
what the constitution is they don't know
what it says they don't care
they want to know
what the latest tweet is or what's on
instagram and they want to spend their
lives here this is where most people
live now right here in this little
machine
i want to take the time to understand
what's happening and why it's happening
and when you get a voting public like
that
you get california you get new york
state you get illinois
and that's what we have
so
it does that what you're explaining
right there really
is the perfect example of what's going
on with the reaction to roe v wade that
nobody really understands this is about
states rights and what is and isn't in
the constitution and i guess to some
extent a certain set of the society just
doesn't care what's in the constitution
they just want it done their way well
not just a certain portion of society
the speaker of the house of
representatives doesn't care what's in
the constitution
nor does the president of the united
states or the senate majority leader
schumer
you think any three of those care what's
in the constitution everybody knew
ruth bader ginsburg knew
that the 1973 ruling
whereby abortion was legal all over the
united states wasn't based
on the constitution
because the right of privacy
is never mentioned
now in the criminal justice system you
have a right of sanctuary in your home
the authorities cannot come into your
home without a warrant without probable
cause
and that happened because the british
the king
they were kicking doors all over the
place so the colonists had no privacy at
all here come the troops boom they'll
take your house
but as far as abortion was concerned was
never mentioned
and because it was never mentioned it
then falls under the 10th amendment as
you know dave
and the 10th amendment of the
constitution says if an issue is not
clearly mentioned
in
the writings here
the amendments of the constitution the
states then decided
and that's what happened with roe v wade
so so what do we do what do we do right
now if obviously everyone everyone in my
audience watching this and hearing you
knows that's true but what do we do if
basically half the country and as you
just said a huge portion of the
political leadership simply don't care
about the documents anymore to me this
seems like a completely intractable
impasse you know you can't negotiate
with people that don't think that the
basic founding the basic documents are
good or are worthy of
paying any attention to or abiding by
i agree that you can't negotiate with
someone like nancy pelosi
i mean her own church her own church
can't negotiate with her she wouldn't
show up to a meeting with the archbishop
of san francisco who wanted to discuss
her advocacy for abortion it's more than
i don't want to impose my view of
abortion on others it's way more than
that nancy pelosi wants as many
abortions in this country
as possible
now how you can be a roman catholic and
all that view it's impossible you can't
but she
doesn't care
what the church says
doesn't care what the constitution says
she is in it for power
she understands her base is left far
left she's going to pander to that base
no matter what the issue is
she's like biden
she has no core belief system at all
other than i believe in power and i want
it
so what do you do with these what do you
do in this situation i mean what are
what are we supposed to do we guys like
us what you can do
80 million voted for just live
yeah i mean look you could move or where
you're gonna move
florida my friend come on down you're
still in new york
but you're still in the united states
yes this is true
if 80 million people are going to vote
for
a guy like joe biden and believe me if
you go back and you look at what
o'reilly said
in october before the november vote of
2020 i predicted everything that was
going to happen because i knew this man
was not capable of doing the job he
cannot do it
all right and everybody has to
understand that
he cannot do it
and so you're putting an incompetent now
you can say it is mental decline i don't
even get into that i'm not a doctor
but he i saw he couldn't campaign
he couldn't utter a cogent sentence in
the debates and i went
this is trouble
but the populist hated donald trump so
much that they put biden in office
and so now we're all paying a price for
that terrible decision who who do you
think is really running the show i mean
it doesn't seem like you think it's by
plane is running the show ron clayne is
the chief of staff and and susan rice is
the
minister of propaganda in the sense that
rice is the ideologue the progressive
ideologue and claine is the
administrator but the most powerful
person in the white house is uh jill
biden so you don't get to talk to joe
biden unless you go through jillbot very
very close to nancy reagan and i wrote
the book killing reagan and nancy after
mr reagan was shot
she controlled access to the president
so does jill
now jill looks to me like to be a far
left zealot
she looks like she's right on board with
rice and clayne and all these others
because
i don't see any moderation in that white
house at all
so i want to talk to you a little bit
about media you know obviously you have
a an extensive sort of remarkable uh
pedigree in mainstream media in uh what
was once mainstream i don't know that
it's mainstream anymore let's say
corporate press and you're doing you're
doing the online thing now which
obviously is the future of all this is
there anything you miss from the daily
cable news grind that you feel like you
got there that you can't get doing what
we're doing now
well i was at fox news for more than 20
years as 16 as the highest rated cable
show in the country by far by the way it
wasn't even close
and i had pretty much done all i could
do
uh for the corporation
and then before that i work with abc
news as a correspondent cbs's is a
correspondent syndicated program called
inside edition so i've basically seen it
and done it all in my career
and uh when i left the daily grind
believe me it was
uh because i write everything i say i
have no writers i never have had any
writers and i design the programs i
don't have producers design them for me
i'm like jerry lewis i do you know i
sweep up after everybody leaves i get
everybody coaxed do you even have a
phone i mean do you have someone that's
doing some fact checking when you're
writing your monologue
checkers and bookers yeah i can't do
that right um but i all the stuff that
you see on screen comes from me and i
was tired
um and it was a big change in management
as everybody knows at fox and it was a
different crew
and i said you know uh
they were gunning for me uh
the far left cadres
um and i didn't think i was going to get
protection and and it just it wasn't
worth it anymore didn't need the money
and then when i got out of there i said
look
the future of uh media
isn't in the corporations they're all
going to go down and they are every one
of them is declining and dramatically
but the future is to develop a news
agency that's independent from all of
that
and present it to the folks and see if
they'll pay for it
and they are
i mean i am making
a lot of money on bill o'reilly.com i'm
not in it for the money i don't do it
for that
but there are
hundreds of thousands of people willing
to pay
for honesty and that's what i provide
you may not agree with me
but i'm gonna back up what i say so i
thought it would work it is working we
are the most successful news agency in
the world now we're a worldwide
operation
and we combine television with radio and
we got more than 300
radio stations across the country
so it's all going my way it's an
enormous amount of work that's for sure
but i'm glad i don't answer to anybody
there's no dopey meetings i don't have
to play uh i never played office
politics i don't have to even be
subjected to that anymore so it's a
relief are there any lefty counterparts
doing something similar to uh what
you've done what i'm doing say you know
there's this sort of broad
new sort of right-leaning conservative
thing happening online that seems really
robust all sorts of different people who
are more traditional conservatives
libertarians ex-libs there's a whole
group of people doing this really
successfully is there anyone that you
see kind of from the other side that's
doing it successfully that you respect
that you try to engage with i'm having a
hard time finding any of these people
willing to talk
yeah i don't i don't live in that world
um i get clip service and i know what
people are saying
um but i don't live in that world but
there isn't anyone
on uh a regular platform on the net
that is looking at it from a moderate
liberal point of view
no one is that is that
is that sad for you i mean you're a long
islander like you grew up i i know i
know where you grew up in long island
i'm a long islander i grew up around a
lot a lot a lot of people who were sort
of moderate liberals and they seemingly
just don't exist anymore
they don't exist anymore and it's
too bad they don't exist anymore i'm a
registered independent a lot of the
moderate liberals have gone into the
independent precincts
um now
but if you are not a doctrinaire
progressive leftist
you get smeared by your own people
i mean they'll attack you they'll turn
on you you gotta get it's got got to be
doctrinaire down the line look what's
happening to bill maher
now bill maher is a very liberal person
extremely so
but he then is fed up with woke and he
look he knows what's absurd because he's
a comedian and that's how he makes his
living he knows biden's absurd
he knows the whole administration is a
catastrophe
well he says that they turn on him fast
do you think he'll love him you think
he'll ever fully turn and do the the
scariest of all things i don't think so
because he lives in hollywood you live
in hollywood
his his cocktail party invites have been
down by about 50 percent i understand if
he goes into traditional precincts he'll
never get invited anywhere and that's
what these people live for that's what
they live for the social aspect of it
that kind of thing accepted in the
bubble manhattan
dc
la
it's boring to me i never wanted to be
in the bubble
um that never affected me at all
i mean i had i produced exec produce uh
four movies
and we were nominated for three emmys
and i was shocked
the movies were really good based on the
killing books
but i was stunned we didn't win because
you're not gonna give o'reilly
an entertainment emmy i won three news
emmys but
um that's a bubble out there in
entertainment that's part of the reason
we're in such a mess
because entertainment industry and the
media news media they're aligned with
the progressive left
and that makes a progressive left far
more powerful than they would be because
they don't have that greater number of
people but the silver lining of course
is that people do seem to be tuning out
and tuning into some of these they are
tuning out no doubt about it so since
you are in new york and you are a true
new yorker uh i often show clips on my
show of kathy hoechel a woman who nobody
voted for who seems to be
probably the second most authoritarian
governor we have in the country maybe to
gavin newsom but she might be number one
like you could probably throw whitmer in
there too what is going on in new york
where where is that spirit of new york
to fight back it's the same thing
that we see in california and illinois
uh one party
in new york democrats outnumber
republicans two to one on the voter
rolls
uh kathy hokel is uh a person who will
never solve any significant problem
she's simply not smart enough it's not
like biden biden's a whole different
thing hulk's just not smart enough
and doesn't particularly care she
doesn't live in new york city she
doesn't care if the city is crime ridden
quality of life is collapsed subways are
dangerous
doesn't care doesn't care that six seven
hundred thousand affluent new yorkers
have left the state uh doesn't care
again power that's what she wants she's
in the machine no bail law she can knock
that out doesn't care
she could fire bragg the uh
prosecutor in manhattan who won't
prosecute any even violent crime she
could fire him won't do it
so
my message to new york voters is this
what you want
apparently it is
apparently it is dave
i don't think long island where i am is
like that anymore long island has
changed
all right but manhattan certainly
doesn't seem to care
whether these people destroy their own
environment
so to that end what do you make of the
the splitting of america in that way
that we're just going to have very very
different states as i think you know i
lived in california for the last eight
years finally moved to florida six
months ago and as i keep telling
everybody i genuinely feel like i live
in another country you're right i do
still live in the united states i
suppose but i live in a free state here
and i did not live in a free state only
3000 miles away
well the social civil war is well
underway it would take a dramatic
populist leader
to
you know speak frankly to the nation and
say is this what you want again it's
just like new york is this what you want
if not let's kind of reason
and find solutions to vexing problems
that's what it's all about problem
solving
progressives they want to knock out
what america is they don't like the
country
they don't care about the constitution
they don't want capitalism
they want equity they want favoritism
for minority groups
they want nothing to do with traditional
america
but again they're not
there there's about 20 25 of those hate
america people and they'll never admit
that by the way they'll always cloak it
but the rest 75 percent
if they would come together they could
overwhelm this destructive progressive
movement but again
they're lost in space cyberspace
and that's what that's what we have
do you sense that maybe some of that's
turning around not only because of the
roe v wade thing which kicks some of
this back to the states but some of the
other decisions the the
concealed carry decision that some of
this stuff is putting the power back in
the hands of the people and maybe that
gets some more people to wake up
no
what's going to get people to wake up is
that they don't have any money
that'll wake them up well then we're not
on our way so
yeah most americans live paycheck to
paycheck
they spend
frivolously they don't think about the
future in saving and security and more
money you have the more power you have
they don't think about it they want what
they want when they want it but now they
have far less money than they had 18
months ago
and that's not going to subside anytime
soon
so the gasoline thing the food thing the
clothing thing uh everything
that's waking up some people who go
these people hurt me
these progressives hurt me biden hurt me
that's far overwhelms abortion gun
control any of that
it's that i'm getting hurt by these
people
so i'm going to vote for the other
people and i think that's what you're
going to see so you think we're in some
kind of red wave situation i mean that's
that's what everyone's saying but i i
keep telling people you got to give the
devil is due it's like they can do
anything right before the elections i
don't even know what i mean by that
exactly covid ii mail in ballots etc etc
who knows well it's coming down fast so
the summer is here and the government
doesn't function in the summer
um and the media doesn't function
either everybody's off they don't care
uh so it fires up again after labor day
and that's just two months before the
midterms it's far too little time for
the biot administration to really do
anything you have a collapsing airline
industry and i'm the poster boy for that
i alerted everybody
uh
that it was happening
uh i got hammered but i don't care what
i did was right it was proper it was
just
uh i shouldn't have cursed it the guy
but
the guy deserved it he deserved it and
i'm an irish guy from long island and
you know you pushed me so far
but anyway uh i do believe that the
republicans will take the house and the
senate i think a lot of democrats will
stay home and i think the hispanic
voting block will go republican and that
will overwhelm the progressives in
november
there's about 20 chance i'm wrong but 80
that i'm right
since you brought it up i have to ask
you're going to turks and caicos you're
ready to get on vacation get out of
there get out of the grinds why not just
fly private bill what are you doing you
got a little cash come on
look
i get up at five in the morning to make
a 7 a.m flight
okay my assistant tracked the flight
plane was there everything was fine
weather was fine
so
i get to the gate
delay
everybody's in the same boat on me one
hour
two hours
three hours four hours five hours
okay dave five hours people are coming
to me
in jfk at the terminal
asking me to do something
right to find out if the plane's going
to take off
right
so they're asking me
so all i did was walk over and ask for a
supervisor
a guy who could barely speak english
came out
i said can you tell us what the
situation is
he gave me attitude
and the rest as they say is history do
you think the airline situation that
that situation where every time you go
to an airport now there's delays
cancellations i mean the last five times
i've been to airports been absolute
disasters uh that that's indicative of
of sort of everything we're talking
about here that the system itself is no
longer functioning properly we don't
hire functioning people we don't hire
people that speak english no but the bug
stops with nobody etcetera this airline
thing could be solved in a week
all right
who's the secretary of transportation
dave that's gay pete that's what we call
him on this show gay pete
okay so buddha judge is in charge
if he wanted to he could levy draconian
fines
on all of the airlines for being delayed
for five hours for no reason remember
delta airlines flew to turks caicos at
the same time and got off so when
jetblue said it was weather everyone
knew they were lying yeah yeah there's a
lot of that yeah okay okay
so buddha judge can say to the airlines
if you don't have a legitimate excuse
for delay or cancellation you're fine
250 000
per flight
you do it got the power to do it
won't do it
now
you say
well that might not be fair the airlines
could appeal the fine
and you set up a little
apparatus for them to do it but i
guarantee you if pete buddha judge the
director of uh secretary of
transportation has the power to do it
did it you would say remarkably
the whole airline industry be
responsible because they're
irresponsible now
so why doesn't pete but a judge do that
i knew you were going to ask that that
was it was coming it was coming
right in your head
because pete drew the judge like
president biden doesn't know what the
deuce he's doing
he is a mayor of south bend indiana
where his biggest decision on thursday
was should we open the park
okay
that's it
he doesn't know how to run anything
he's an affirmative action hire yeah
that's why we call him here
pete buddha judge knows it
the byte administration came in didn't
hire on merit
who can we find out who really
understands transportation so we don't
have supply line problems
and we can get the airlines regulated so
they take off who can we get who really
knows that wasn't it
it was well we need a lifestyle guy
here's pete
okay kamala harris is she qualified to
run the president to run the uh united
states of america dave is kamala harris
qualified to run it was his country she
does know that ukraine is small and that
russia's big that counts as something
doesn't it
no
she's there because she's an affirmative
action hire
so when you have an incompetent at the
top biden he's comfortable hiring other
incompetents
that's the way it is that's what we have
all right so let's move from
incompetence to perhaps some competence
that could maybe get involved in this
obviously you're an admirer and friend
of uh president trump and you guys did
your tour together for quite some time
uh we've got a great situation going on
here in florida with ron desantis what
do you make of what's going to happen
with the republicans and and do you have
any insight into what trump's going to
do i mean it all seems like he's going
that every day it's another hint that
seems where it's all headed right
yeah i mean no doubt trump wants to run
for president and 24 he's raising money
to do so he has an announce because if
he announces now in 22 campaign finance
laws immediately kick in that will
constrict his fundraising for his
political action committees so he's not
going to
formally announce till next year
um
donald trump has problems uh no doubt
about it
uh he didn't handle uh the sixth january
sixth thing well
uh he continues to harp on the election
which is not a good political way to be
because he does have a strong record
have you said that
about january 6 yeah
he doesn't listen to anybody donald
trump never listens to anybody's part of
his charm
he never has listened to anybody the
only person on earth that donald trump
ever listened to
was his father fred trump okay and that
was about business not politics
so anyway um
donald trump if you
and that's what the history tour that i
went out with trump on
if you look at the way he
ran the country
he was very successful because he ran it
on a deal-making opposition the reason
they didn't have trouble with putin is
because
trump made a deal with putin i don't
know what that deal is but they had a
deal now putin's hackers they caused a
little bit trouble but putin himself
didn't
as soon as trump was gone
taliban in afghanistan putin and russia
and myriad others said okay now we got a
weak guy we don't have trump because
trump's
he's going to hurt us
and that's why i wrote killing the
killers i show you
in that book how trump handled isis
al-qaeda and the iranians
it was pretty tough
i don't think you could get tougher
all right and nobody knows about this
it's all classified information we
haven't killing the killers but anyway
trump ran the country in my opinion but
i i'm not some guy who comes in and i
just root for people i don't do that
uh he ran the country well donald trump
did
um but he doesn't even campaign on that
it's all about the election
the election's not going to be
overturned and here's the real kicker on
it if trump is reelected he could then
appoint a special counsel to investigate
the election
he'd have the power to do that
but to just run around
and keep doing it and do it people are
tired of it
so he's not a lock
desantis as you mentioned ran florida
pretty pretty well or is running florida
pretty well conservative doctrinaire
um
so desantis would be a formidable
opponent
so let's shift a little bit to the book
because you talk about some of the way
that trump ran policy to get some of
these things done when we ran foreign
policy somewhat effectively unlike what
we're doing today um you've done
obviously many of these books i mean
first off where did the original idea
for the killing series come from
me
all the ideas come from me
um so i wanted to
use my knowledge of history
to inform people about their country
uh in an entertaining way and it's as i
mentioned
succeeded beyond anyone's expectations
so what we did with killing the killers
was
i
i know everybody dave
i know wherever you've been around the
block man so
i contacted the national security
advisers beginning with david petraeus
and the bush administration all the way
up to the end of the trump
administration and i told them they're
all men
i said look
i need to know what happened in certain
areas
i'm not going to quote you i'm not going
to use your name it's just background
tell me the truth
but i will verify it in other places
and they all did
so i got an amazing stuff stuff nobody's
ever heard before so how do they how do
they go about doing that i'm always
amazed by that so are they redacted are
they redacting specific locations like
you're getting general locations and
then you slightly have to change them no
no no i say look you wax stole the money
so imani got waxed okay
how did that happen
and they tell a story
and i
write it down
and i put it in the book but there's got
to be some stuff there telling you you
can't write down right
i didn't leave anything out
i didn't leave anything out
solar money is the most powerful person
in iran more powerful than the ayatollah
that okay
and the way that america tracked and
assassinated him
it's unbelievable
remember trump spent 1.4 trillion
dollars on the military nobody knows
where that money went
a lot of it went into space surveillance
and weaponry stuff china and russia
don't have
what we have
and all of that is in a book
and when people read the book and
hundreds of thousands bought it
uh they're going whoa
because
a regular reporter will never get that
stuff
ever in a million years
and then when somebody would tell me
something about solomoni or we open with
the bin laden raid what really happened
and we ended with the debacle of biden
in afghanistan
so that's how
the book is all throughout that time
frame
but
when i got information
i verified it
through people who were there
okay on the raids themselves
and that's what
you call reporting and killing the
killer is the best reporting i've ever
done in my career how would you grade
our mission if you go from exactly what
you said the book covers from the
assassination
of bin laden taking out bin laden to
the disastrous way we left afghanistan i
mean can you put a grade on that or i
guess there's a curve but
the thing i say is that americans are
well protected by the cia and nsa
national security agency
those agencies work very effectively
unfortunately they don't have any sway
inside the united states we have an open
border inexplicably why biden did that
nobody nobody knows
but terrorists have gotten in through
that southern border now the fbi takes
that over
and i have no confidence at this point
in history in the fbi
none
[Music]
so
there's a time bomb
but overseas
we put a hurt on those people
afghanistan uh
you know al-qaeda is there
reconstituting but we can listen to
almost every one of their transmissions
same thing at isis in iraq boko haram
and africa we have ground troops in
africa right now as we're speaking
nobody knows it they're fighting the
isis people and boko haram people there
so
americans are well protected from
overseas jihadists
but is a growing threat within
what what did you learn about the
afghanistan withdrawal that perhaps we
don't it was ridiculous we don't know i
mean we all saw these totally ridiculous
yeah right so every
national security person told by
you can't do this you can't cut and run
you've got to keep bagram air force base
and i've been to bagram i've been to
afghanistan you've got to keep that as
a safe zone
all right it's got to be armed you've
got to have air power there you've got
to keep the terrorists incarcerated
there
can't give it up biden rejected all of
it
just gave it up along with all of our
military equipment he led one thousand
hardcore terrorists out of bagram prison
one of those terrorists three days later
killed 13 u.s service people at the
kabul airport
biden has no clue
about anything and that you know people
say oh riley you know you hate him and
you're an ideologue i'm not
this is a flat out analysis the man
cannot understand
does not have the intellectual capacity
to understand
what is happening in this world
well that's a scary thought huh he's the
second worst president in our history
so far in 18 months only james buchanan
who pretty much caused the civil war
before lincoln
tops him
now maybe by don't make a stunning
comeback i guess it's possible
but i don't think so
so when we left and it was a disaster on
all fronts uh were you able to talk to
any of our generals who i mean they
didn't get what they wanted i would
never talk to a general
ever on any project would i speak with a
general
generals are not in the business of
telling anyone the truth
they're in the business of keeping their
power
so generals are not in i talked to
look
i know what happened in afghanistan
because i know people
who advise biden against it
see
and
so i know
that biden rejected
everything that was presented to him
for a cut and run strategy
that was you know embarrassing for and
emboldened putin and everybody else all
over the world
all right bill i know you're tight on
time here so now you know when you often
have ended your shows with the final
word and your final thoughts i always
try to end my shows giving people a
little positivity through this political
madness that we are in right now because
it always feels like it's just getting
worse and crazier and all of those
things um so despite biden despite the
craziness of the woke despite all the
stuff that's happening right now and the
economy and everything else
what gets you going in the morning to
make you want to keep doing this when
you don't have to do it and well to
fight for my motivation is to
bring information to people they they
don't know but just think back two years
ago
just two years ago the american economy
was vibrant robust
working people's wages were going up
quickly
we had no supply problems we had plenty
of fuel
gas prices hovered around two dollars
and 30 cents
we had plenty of food we had plenty of
baby formula we had a border that was
locked down as best the government could
do it with uh
the migrant intrusion cut 75
that was just two years ago
okay
so i say to people it's a disaster now
it is a disaster but it goes in cycles
it goes in cycles history goes in cycles
the one disturbing point is people in
places like new york california illinois
they don't seem to be learning their
lesson
so those states
i'm not sure but the country in general
will come back
as boris johnson said yesterday
when cnn tried to bait him into saying
america was a fading power johnson said
no
our resources here and the resources are
the people the hard-working honest
people of this country can bring this
country back
but everybody needs
honest information and insight in order
to build that base and that's why i'm
here well bill you were the first cable
news show that i was ever a guest on
probably a decade ago so i appreciate
you coming on and joining me the book is
killing the killers we're going to link
to it right down below and my parents
often see you on the beach in long
island so one of these days i'm going to
bump into you out there
all right don't frighten me though just
show them
it'll be a subtle tap don't worry okay
thanks man
giuliani you know what i mean
thanks for having me on the program dave
all right bye-bye
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell